bonsoir nous sommes le 8 avril nouvelle
édition du Journal de la rédaction le 78
lactu avant de découvrir les principaux
titres nous allons faire le bilan le
point sur le siteaction 2014 Jérôme
André de l'association hchef Prévention
est avec nous par téléphone association
nationale de lutte contre le virus du
sida et les infections sexuellement
transmissible bonsoir Jérôme André oui
bonsoir le site d'action cette année 5
millions d'euros de promesse de don un
chiffre stable par rapport à 2013 est-ce
que dans les evelines les promesses de
don ont été fortes également alors
effectivement il y a eu beaucoup de
mobilisation dans les evelines nous on
s'est d'ailleurs mobilisé sur la gare de
saquentin en Yveline mais aussi donc
Saint-Germain en lait il y a eu pas mal
de lycées cette année qui se sont
mobilisés d'ailleurs l'année prochaine
on pense les fédérer beaucoup plus vous
l'avez dit 5 millions c'est pas mal en
tout tout cas c'est stable par rapport à
l'année dernière on aimerait bien qu'il
y ait effectivement plus d'augmentation
donc pour le S d'action néanmoins on se
rend bien compte que le sida aujourd'hui
ce n'est plus une cause qui donc fait
penser au français qu'il faut encore
donner malheureusement c'est important
de le rappeler on meurt encore
aujourd'hui du sida et c'est vrai qu'il
y a pas mal de problématiques qui sont
liées donc à cela notamment par le fait
qu' les gens donc n'utilisent plus trop
le préservatif c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'on sort prochainement une application
iPhone
pour géolocaliser donc ce type donc
d'outil de prévention qui est donc le
préservatif 5 millions d'euros de
promesse de don au niveau national à
quoi sert cet argent justement
concrètement à développer aussi la
recherche les actions de sensibilisation
rappeler qu'il faut toujours et encore
se
protéger exactement c'est important de
souligner que l'association Sidaction
qui est une association donc un fond
donc qui va permettre à des association
mais aussi à des chercheurs de faire
progresser donc la lutte contre le sida
la recherche en général
on dit souvent strictement de manière
très
stricte 1 € reversé donc aussi d'action
c'est 50 centimes pour les associations
donc de recherche donc ça va être des
chercheurs de linerme et autres et 50
centimes donc qui est reversé donc à une
association pour des projets des projets
de lutte contre donc le sida et
notamment pour faire progresser aussi la
prévention en France de intervention
justement sur le terrain ce weekend
encore vous l'avez constaté vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure on meurt encore et
toujours du sida vous avez constaté que
peut-être même les jeunes et les moins
jeunes était mal informé aujourd'hui on
a le sentiment que c'est une maladie
finalement dont on peut guérir alors
effectivement le vrai souci qui se pose
c'est ça c'est que on a des gens qui en
de nous pensent qu'on qu'on guérit du
sida qu'il existe un vaccin qu'on va
avoir donc des gens qui se disent bien à
la limite c'est plus très grave d'êt
céropositif non c'est important de
rappeler qu'il y a des vraies
problématiques on MEUR toujours du sida
et que malgré les avancées
thérapeutiques notamment grâce à la
recherche aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
d'effits encore indésirables quand on
est effectivement une personnne
séropositive et c'est donc toujours
dangereux de devenir donc séropositive
d'où le fait d'intensifier donc la
prévention parce que et ça c'est des
chiffres qui sont beaucoup plus réels
hein pour les ISV Linois c'est important
de rappeler que quand on passe dans un
centre commerciale ou dans une
université 1,25 % des jeunes ou des
moins jeunes dans les C commerciaux sont
séropositifs et découvrent leur
séropositivité donc avec nous lors des
unités donc de dépistage donc c'est
important de rappeler que on trouve
encore beaucoup de séropositifs parmi
des gens qui n'utilisent pas le
préservatif qui ne sont plus habitués à
pouvoir donc se protéger le Sidaction
qui se poursuit encore il est encore
possible de donner jusqu'au 15 avril via
le 110 ou sur sidaction.org merci Jérôme
André d'avoir été en ligne avec nous
pour faire ce premier bilan de cette
opération merci à vous on passe à
présent au titre de ce 8 avril dans le
78 lactu de ce soir 9e semaine de
mobilisation en faveur du don de moelle
osseuse objectif 18000 nouveau donneurs
chaque année ce sont plus de 2000
personnes attenties d'une maladie grave
du sang qui en ont besoin nouveau succès
pour les Journées Européennes des
Métiers d'Art de nombreux artisans ont
ouvert leurs portes les portes de leurs
ateliers durant 3 jours ils ont livré
quelques-uns de leurs secrets et puis
régulièrement l'association fly and Kiss
réalise les rêves d'enfants en situation
de handicap des baptêmes de l'air au
départ de l'aérodrome de saint-s l'école
pour oublier le temps d'un instant la
maladie nous partons donc pour débuter
pour saincè l'école ou des enfants des
hôpitaux de Versailles autiste oussour
ont réalisé grâce à l'association fly
and Kiss un voyage dans les nuages un
baptème de l'air financé grâce au
sponsors mais aussi aux donateurs yolè
Torz et Jonathan
villman c'était leur rêve le voici
maintenant réalisé il y a quelques jours
à l'aérodrome de saint-sire l'école une
cinquantaine d'enfants malades ont fait
leur baptême de l'air ils en ont plein
les yeux et certains comme Matthieu ont
même le privilège de toucher aux
commandes j'ai aimé de de faire un peu
comme les
oiseaux c'est de de pouvoir
être en hauteur et puis pouvoir faire
quand même pouvoir bouger comme on veut
j'ai vu le château de
versaill des girafes des éléphants et la
tour etelle c'était beau
et
cool pour organiser cette journée
l'association fly and Kiss a mobilisé
des avions 4at places et quelques
pilotes en 2 ans ils ont permis 400
baptêmes de l'air et pour cette année
2014 leur objectif est d'offrir cette
chance à 300 enfants supplémentaire des
enfants souvent très renfermés par leur
maladie mais qui en plein vol se découvr
et s'ouvre un peu au monde au mois
d'octobre l'année dernière deux enfants
autistes qui n'avaient absolument jamais
parlé et qui ont dit leurs premierers
mots dans la avion pendant le vol ça m'a
taé rapporté puisque moi j'étais pas
dans l'avion mais pour moi voilà c'est
quelque chose de formidable et ce qui
montre bien que même si rien
néprouvé au niveau médical ça leur ouvre
une dimension qu'ils ne connaissent pas
et ça ouvre ça ouvre une brèche dans
leur dans leur enfermement quelque part
et et on les voit on les sent heureux on
les voit heureux et ça c'est formidable
les enfants ont aussi profité des
ateliers proposés notamment celui de
construction d'avion miniature parmi les
organisations partenaires de cette
journée la délégation ivelinoise de
l'association Rêve depuis 20 ans son
objectif premier est de faire oublier la
maladie aux enfants partir en avion
c'est oublier tous ces soins qui sont
lourds à traiter tous ces médicaments
tous ces temps passés à l'hôpital c'est
un
moment partir ailleurs rêver faire autre
chose et puis partager tous ensemble
parce que les parents se retrouvent les
enfants les bénévoles on forme une
grande famille et puis on est
ensemble grâce à cette association
justement la petite hlan courtoise n'en
finit pas de voir ses vœux se réaliser
elle se rend sur les piste de ski pour
la première fois cette
semaine et lors de cette journée la
délégation yvelinoise de l'association
Rêve a souhaitait passer un message au
petit Lucas actuellement hospitalisé en
raison de sa maladie il ne pouvait pas
se rendre sur ses baptêmes proposés par
flyen Kiss comme on va le voir sur ces
images les représentants de la
délégation lui envoient de gros bisous
et nous nous joignons bien évidemment à
eux une très chaleureuse pensée au petit
Lucas et à sa famille invité de cette
édition du 8 avril le professeur Jean
hugdal bonsoir bonsir vous êtes
hématologue à l'hôpital Debray à Paris
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
et d'avoir pris le temps de venir
jusqu'à nous l'Agence de biomédecine
organise une 9e semaine de mobilisation
en faveur du don de moile osseuse c'est
jusqu'au 12 avril aujourd'hui la
priorité c'est d'augmenter sensiblement
le le nombre de donneurs ceux qui
deviendront des veilleurs de vie puisque
c'est le terme consacré plus les
donneurs sont nombreux plus les profils
génétiques peuvent ensuite correspondre
avec les personnes qui en ont besoin
avec exactement en fait dans la
population générale le la probabilité de
trouver quelqu'un qui est compatible
avec vous c'est une chance sur 1 million
don c'est extrêmement faible et pour
augmenter un tout petit peu ces chancesl
bien effectivement plus on aura d'neur
sur les fichier et plus on aura de
chances de trouver le bon donneur pour
le patient qui en a besoin l'objectif
2400 nouveaux donneurs juste pour
l'Île-de-France puisque nous sommes dans
les chiffres he quelques éléments clés
sur l'année 2013 plus de 25000 donneurs
inscrits sur le registre national dans
la région Île-de-France ça fait plus de
220000 personnes au niveau national 284
greffes sur la région aussi réalisé
grâce au dons volontaire de de moelle
osseuse dans quel cas la greffe de
moelle osseuse est nécessaire sur quel
type de maladie alors sont
essentiellement les maladies
hématologiques pas uniquement en
pédiatrie il y a quelques indications
supplémentaires mais c'est
essentiellement des maladies
hématologiques et en premier lieu c'est
la leucémie ou les leucémies parce qu'il
y a pas qu'une seule leucémie donc c'est
la maladie de la moelle osseuse la la
zone du corps qui produit les cellules
du sang les globules blancs les globules
rouges les plaquettes pour une raison
qu'on ne connaît pas un individu va
pouvoir développer une leucémie qui va
être prise en charge par de la
chimiothérapie mais parfois cette
chimiothérapie ne va pas être suffisante
il va falloir terminer finalement le le
travail de la chimiothérapie par la
greffe de moile et pour faire une greffe
on a besoin d'un donneur on peut
peut-être insister sur le rôle pour le
fonctionnement de la machine du corps
humain de la moelle osseuse à quoi sert
la moile osseuse alors donc à produire
les cellules du sang évidemment le sang
c'est la vie et c'est c'est finalement
le sens de ce acronyme les les veilleurs
de vie parce que le sang c'est la vie
donc les globules rouges qui nous
donnent nos couleurs qui sont là pour
transporter l'oxygène depuis les poumons
jusque l'ensemble de l'organisme dans
tous les tous les tissus de l'organisme
les globules blancs les globules rouges
pardon vont allez porter distribuer de
l'oxygène et récupérer le CO2 pour
ensuite l'éliminer via les poumons les
plaquettes qui nous empêchent de saigner
hein permanence on donne des petit coup
et on saignerait si on avait pas ces
plaquettes qui viennent former des
petits bouchons là où on se blesse et
puis les globules blancs qui sont les
cellules qui vont nous empêcher
essentiellement de nous infecter qui
vont en permanence reconnaître ce que
nous sommes et rejeter ce qui est
étranger à notre corps et évidemment en
premier lieu les microbes d'où le rôle
extrêmement important de la moelle
osseuse le don de moelle osseuse est
encore malgré tout un méconnu même si
c'est déjà la 9e semaine de
sensibilisation 9e année consécutive
vous allez nous expliquer comment cela
fonctionne pour un don pour les
personnes qui voudraient justement
devenir des des veilleurs de de vie
auparavant et avant d'écouter vos
explications micro trottoir nous sommes
vous allez vous poser cette question Que
savez-vous que connaissez-vous du don de
moelle osseuse vos réponses avec ce
micro trottoir donc pas grandchose j'en
ai entendu parler récemment il doit y
avoir une campagne en ce moment c'est
que c'est très rare d'être compatible
que ça se fait entre dans la famille je
crois qu'on peut le faire de son vivant
pas comme les dons d'organes il me
semble non je sais pas grandchose que il
y a pas beaucoup de donneur en France
moins pas assez il faut sensibiliser
davantage les gens par de l'image déjà
ça choque davantage ça marque c'est très
important il y a une pratique
chirurgicale je crois qu'on doit faire
des euh à l'aide d'un outil le long de
la colonne vertébrale faire un
prélèvement c'est assez douloureux et
qu'il faut après donner les
plaquettes aux personnes qu'on ont
besoin c'est un petit peu la l'étape
supérieure au don du sang et c'est
finalement méconnu il y a eu quelques
approximations quelques erreurs même
dans le micro trottoir on va bien
évidemment les corriger 9e semaine de
mobilisation autour du don de la moelle
osseuse professeur d donc va pouvoir
nous en dire plus tout d'abord si on
décide de devenir donneur comment cela
fonctionne ce n'est pas aussi simple que
de donner son sang ça n'est pas aussi
simple mais c'est pas tellement
compliqué et surtout je crois que là
encore on revient sur les veilleurs de
vie euh vous déclarez que vous vous êtes
susceptible de donner votre Mo mais
finalement vous ne la donnez pas vous la
donnez extrêmement rarement bien sûr
vous décidez d'aller donner votre sang
vous tendez le bras vous donnez le sang
voilà vous décidez de bien vouloir être
donneur de moile c'est une déclaration
d'intention c'est une déclaration
d'intention extrêmement importante parce
qu'on en a besoin de ces déclarations
d'intention mais le plus souvent le
donneur de moil ne reste que putatif
donc il faut pas en avoir peur parce que
il faut y réfléchir avant de le faire il
faut pas se déclarer d'honneur pour
reculé bien sûr ce serait pas une bonne
chose mais ça peut se faire par étape
alors par contre c'est au même endroit
que le don du sang ce sont dans les les
les antennes des établissements français
du sang alors tous les établissements
toutes les antennes ne reçoivent pas des
des donneurs de de moelle mais c'est
assez simple de trouver ça sur internet
sur le le site de de l'Agence de
biomédecine par exemple ou euh de de
donneur de sangou donneur de moile vous
allez trouver l'antenne proche de chez
vous et puis là il va y avoir euh un
interrogatoire pour essayer de voir si
vous avez ou non d'éventuelles
contreindications au don de moile il y
en a quelques-unes elles ne sont pas
nombreuses mais il y en a quelques-unes
et puis si effectivement vous
satisfaisez à ce premier filtre
finalement il va y avoir une prise de
sang
qui va d'une part permettre de typer de
d'identifier ce que vous êtes en terme
d'immunologie puisque c'est l'immunité
qui va définir la compatibilité avec un
éventuel patient qui aurait besoin de
vous et qui va aussi dépister
d'éventuelles maladies infectieuse parce
qu'il est évidemment pas question en
voulant rendre service à un patient lui
transmettre une maladie infectieuse donc
on va avoir quelques quelques contrôle
au niveau au niveau infectieux donc être
en bonne santé de 18 à 50 ans aussi he
c'est la tranche d'âge et qui est
concerné alors comment ça se passe
ensuite si finalement on est appelé et
qu'on peut devenir donneur ce n'est pas
immédiat on doit pas se rendre du jour
au lendemain non et ça je crois que
c'est extrêmement important c'est de se
rendre compte que on va pas devoir tout
arrêter tout à faire ses cendre quitter
son travail quitter sa famille pour
aller donner sa moile c'est toujours
quelque chose qui peut se programmer ça
se programme rapidement mais ce
rapidement ça va être quelques semaines
on a toujours le temps de s'organiser et
puis on a le temps aussi éventuellement
de dire non
là
av je suis disponible du ou 12 mai alors
parfois le centre receveur celui qui a
cherché à vous contacter va dire non le
patient peut pas
attendre et ça va vous être dit puis
vous allez voir si vous pouvez ajuster
votre emploi du temps et puis vous avez
le droit de dire non là c'est pas
possible je suis étudiant je me suis
inscrit j'ai une session d'examen qui
tombe juste au moment difficile pour
unud voul faire cette cette démarche
altruiste mais je joue mon avenir bon on
a le temps de passer les examens et puis
si vraiment c'est pas cette fois-ci
bien un certain nombre de patients ont
aussi plusieurs donneurs potentiel et
alors on va se tourner person qui voulit
dir des veilleurs des veilleurs de vie
donc l'acte médical ça se passe comment
alors dans le micro trottoir on a
entendu on fait un prélèvement au niveau
au niveau du dos dans la colonne
vertébrale c'est pas tout à fait ça
parce que c'est pas la moelle épinière
dont on parle voilà père et c'est vrai
alors je suis surpris de ce micro
trottoir parce que quand même je pense
qu'on voit très bien et bien il y a eu 8
semaines 8 années précédentes sur la
sensibilisation parce que je pense qu'il
y a 8 ans on aurait eu des des réponses
complètement différentes et pour la
plupart erroné alors que là c'est fin ce
que nous ont dit vos vos vos
téléspectateurs c'est c'est assez
intéressant alors effectivement c'est
pas la moi l'épinière donc c'est pas la
colonne vertébrale c'est essentiellement
les eau du bassin de la moile osseuse on
en a dans tous les EAU on peut aller en
chercher par exemple dans le sternum
mais c'est une petite zone il en aura
pas beaucoup alors qu'il y a une
quantité importante de moelle
hématopoétique productrice des cellules
du sang dans les eau du bassin et donc
on va essentiellement al il y a deux
techniques mais si on parle de don de
moile ça va se passer sous anesthésie
générale on va donc être complètement
endormi on va pas pouvoir se réveiller
pendant le don il y a pas de problème
pas forcément douloureux aussi
parceonend pas forcément doulourux
alors non puis je crois que quand on
fait un don
altruiste il y a une certaine fierté
c'est
on est satisfait de l'avoir fait et
quand on interview les les donneurs
après parce qu'on les revoit toujours
après on leur demande bon vous avez fait
mal pas oui il y a quelques heures au
réveil qui sont un peu inconfortables un
peu comme si on s'était cogné contre un
meuble finalement mais c'est des
douleurs qui sont supportables et puis
qui passent assez assez vite puis
forcément on vient en aide à une autre
personne on vient sauver la vie
forcément de de quelqu'un ensuite avec
cette greffe on parlait au début de cet
entretien de l'objectif d'augmenter le
nombre de de donneurs potentiels en
France et c'est important parce qu'il y
a cette diversité aussi en France
génétique qui permettrait de répondre à
toutes les demandes exactement
exactement on est euh tous homme ou
femme il y a pas de race à proprement
parler mais il y a des ethnies et dans
une dans deux ethnies différentes
l'immunité n'est pas strictement la même
et les chances de trouver un donneur
compatible sont plus grandes dans la
même ethnie et comme nous avons une
population multiethnique et bien on a
besoin de donneur multiethnique aussi et
que quand on regarde e les fichiers
alors qu'il s'agit du fichier français
du fichier allemand qui est extrêmement
important des fichiers nord-américains
il y a une surreprésentation de ce que
nous nous appelons les donneurs
caucasiens des blancs or tous nos
patients ne sont pas blancs ne sont pas
caucasiens et on a besoin de
sensibiliser les populations d'origine
différentes parce qu'ils vont pouvoir
venir en aide à des patients d'origine
différente et on a besoin de tout le
monde merci d'être venu nous parler de
ce don de moileosseuse en plateau 9e
semaine de sensibilisation avec l'Agence
de biomédecine l'établissement français
du sang il participe également il y a un
site internet dédié vous pourrez voir
les les rendez-vous éventuellement de
sensibilisation qui sont proposés les
facultés de médecine sont très impliqué
les étudiants sont impliqués justement
parce que ce sont eux les médecins les
chirurgiens de demain et qu'il faut
qu'ils puissent passer le message
forcément passer le message et ce sont
les meilleurs donneurs ce sont les plus
jeunes merci professeur d'êtreevenenu en
plateau responsable du service
hématologie à l'hôpital de Bray à Paris
on change complètement de de sujet la
semaine du développement durable qui
vient de se terminer des événements ét
organisés afin d'apprendre à mieux
consommer à limiter son impact impact
sur l'environnement parmi les opérations
retiendra également celle menée à
manilamoot nettoyage de la nature afin
de sensibiliser également au tri des
déchets Olivier Maniscalco et Yve hston
berger une journée consacrée au bien de
la nature le 5 avril la commune de
maniléamo a donné rendez-vous à ses
citoyens pour le traditionnel nettoyage
de printemps un nettoyage qui débutait
par un stand d'information sur le parvie
de la mairie l'objectif dialoguer et
apprendre sur le tri des déchets dessin
animés pédagogique jeu de tri ou
échantillon une association accueillit
le public pour faire comprendre
l'urgence de la situation il est temps
que les gens prennent conscience ben de
la pollution qui peut-être évitée grâce
au tri on a de plus en plus de poubelles
on peut arriver jusqu'à 500 kg de
d'ordure ménagère par habitant en France
par an c'est énorme quatre parcours de
nettoyage démarrit ensuite de l'Hôtel de
Ville réunissant 50 personnes jeunes et
moins jeunes deux parcours en lisière de
forêt et deux parcours en cœur de ville
avec le même but sensibiliser le public
à la protection de
l'environnement on a la chance sur
manilamo d'avoir beaucoup d'espac verts
et justement on se rend compte au
travers de ces espaces verts qui a quand
même pas mal de déchets dessus c'est un
petit peu moins eu agréable pour eux
pour pour jouer pour s'amuser donc le
l'idéal c'est de les responsabiliser à
ce niveau-là et qu'il sachent que bah
c'est à eux de préserver aussi
l'environnement dans lequel ils sont
c'est pas la première fois qu'on y
participe c'est ça fait plusieurs anné
qu'on le fait et je trouve ça utile quoi
en fin d'après-midi les déchets étaient
réunis sur le parvis pour un tri méteau
vert et plastique séparé le tout était
ensuite acheminé vers la
déchetterie culture à présent à
l'occasion des Journées européenne des
métiers d'art les visiteurs des grandes
eau au château de Versailles ont pu
assister exceptionnellement à une
démonstration des opérations de
restauration du bassin de la tonne qui
se déroule actuellement un voyage au
cœur des métiers d'art avec Aelia debiss
et Jonathan villman
Laurent Bouillot est tailleur de pierre
sa spécialité la restauration de
monuments historiques installé au cœur
du petit parc à Versailles il présente
aux visiteurs ses savoir-faire dans le
cadre des Journées Européennes des
Métiers d'Art cet événement annuel
organisé partout en France invite le
public à découvrir pendant 3 jours des
métiers d'exception la restauration en
cours du bassin de la tonne est
l'occasion pour les visiteurs d'échanger
avec les artisans d'art sur leur
technique l'héritage de savoir-faire et
or au fil des siècles on essaie de
toujours de se de se conformer à la
taille d'époque d'être au plus près de
ce qui se faisait quand on aura monté
l'ensemble de la VAE il faut pas qu'on
voit les les éléments neufs au milieu
des élémentsci il faut que tout soit
homogène donc il y a un travail de un
petit peu de vieillissement de patine
aussi on va on va mettre des couleurs à
l'aide de Lian à l'aide de terre de
façon à à colorer un petit peu la
surface de la pierre légèrement pour
s'adapter au couleur des pierres
anciennes ouis voilà ah effectivement la
partie vue elle doit être parfaite elle
doit être taillée exactement comme une
pierre qui était taillée à l'époque de l
14 donc on doit avoir la même taille la
même définition la même finition
d'ouvrage la finition se fait au maillet
au ciseaux avec des taillants uniquement
les outils qui pouvaient être disponible
à l'époque on va pas utiliser une
machine moderne pour la finition autre
technique de restauration celle des
métaux cette fois-ci plus modernes
Philippe Pagnon chaudronier uvre à la
conservation du décor sculpté de la
fontaine qui abrite les habitants des
marais nous on a la soudure aussi
asséinique avec du plomb pur
donc qui se prte bien voilà sur ce genre
de sculpture on emploie donc les
techniques
d'aujourd'hui pour restaurer les œuvres
la difficulté c'est de restaurer l'œuvre
sans la dénaturer pendant toute la durée
du chantier le château de versaill
invite le public à découvrir le travail
exceptionnel des artisans d'art les
prochains rendez-vous auront lieu les 16
et 23 mai puis le 19
juin la Grande Guerre faête son
centenaire et à cette occasion le club
de généalogie d'élancour racine a
consacré une partie de sa manifestation
annuelle au poilu un travail mené à
partir du Monument aux Morts de la
commune c'était ce weekend dans les
locaux de la Maison de quartier de la
ville dieieu Antony
reche avant la guerre de 1418 ETL en
courour compté 350 âmes mais 10 poilus
ne rentreront pas au village pris par
l'horreur du conflit un siècle après
cette exposition retrace leur vie de
leur lieu de naissance à leur rôle
pendant la guerre et le nom de leur
régiment le club racine a recherché
toutes les traces de ces hommes tombé
pour la France la plupart est l'an
courtois bien sûr la plupart était
agriculteur certains étaient mariés
d'autres pas sur les 10 on avait quand
même quatre qui étaient mariés avvec des
familles malheureusement ben sont morts
et pour d'autres ben surtout des gens de
la terre puisque el encour comme vous le
savez c'était une un village rural donc
la plupart était quand même beaucoup
d'agriculteurs quelques rares clichés
des médailles de ses poilures retracent
leur guerre à eux si chacun s'étonne
devant ces documents unique ces
recherches dans le passé permettent
avant tout de ne pas oublier les
millions de personnes disparues au cours
du conflit tout ce qui a trait à la
guerre 1418 c'est intéressant je pense
que tout le monde devrait un peu s'y
intéresser et et puis tout en fait c'est
pas que l'histoire de remonter une
généalogie le grand-père enfin le père
le grand-père et cetera c'est aussi
historique c'est l'histoire de nos
régions Pays plus aucun poilu ne peut
retranscrire l'ignominiie de la Première
Guerre mondiale pourtant les
contemporains sont de plus en plus
nombreux à vouloir retrouver leurs
ancêtres internet documents
administratifs tout est bon pour
retracer son histoire c'est le documents
qui est une grande tente qui est morte
en 74 qui avait gardé les tout les
dossiers de son de son frère l'abbé
Gérard il l'avait gardé et donc j'ai
c'est moi qui a récupéré là où il est
passé dans tous les parce que il a s'est
déplacé à chaque fois il allait sur le
front il se déplaçait donc lui il était
pas combattant il était ramassé les
bless si vous aussi vous voulez
connaître vos origines le club racine
pourra vous aider à décrypter des
documents anciens trois fois par
semaine prochaine édition du 78 lactu
demain mercredi 18 8h je vous retrouve
également ce mardi soir 18h30 19h30 et
23h pour le premier numéro du 78
politique et je recevrai Philippe
Chevrier secrétaire départemental du
Front national dans le département à
demain